with rising tension in Russia and the  Middle East will you support the need  for the Trident nuclear deterrent where  do you stand on the Trident nuclear  deterrence so I think we should keep the  nuclear deterrent in this unsafe world  but I don't think we need to keep it on  the same on the same basis in which was  originally designed to flatten Moscow at  the press of a button and this comes  down to basically whether the Trident  nuclear system has four nuclear  submarines or three nuclear submarines  and whether you need a nuclear submarine  absolutely 24 hours a day 365 days of  the whole year going around the world I  personally think we can step down the  nuclear ladder while keeping ourselves  safe and that I think is a sensible  balanced way to keep ourselves safe but  not spend huge amounts of money on a  cold war replacement to the nuclear  Trident system which just doesn't fit  the post-cold war world that we live in  the